[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con mi nombre es
ángela gómez tras las protestas del 11
de julio en cuba la isla está en los
titulares internacionales por las
demandas ciudadanas contra la profunda
crisis económica que ahora afecta
también el manejo de la pandemia y es
que el país caribeño presentó en los
últimos días recortes de contagios y
reportó escasez de oxígeno para
pacientes de kobe el gobierno que
reconoce la crisis culpa a estados
unidos de orquestar las movilizaciones y
lo responsabiliza por el bloqueo
histórico para comprender mejor lo que
sucede en cuba nos acompaña desde buenos
aires argentina andrés servín doctor en
ciencias políticas analista
internacional y presidente de la
coordinadora regional de investigaciones
económicas y sociales
bienvenidos france24 y comienzo
preguntando cuál es la influencia real
de eeuu en los episodios de protesta que
hemos visto desde el domingo en cuba es
el bloqueo económico la dificultad clave
para entender lo que pasan los
ciudadanos
lo que pasa con los ciudadanos en
realidad está más vinculado con su vida
cotidiana y el impacto de la escasez
generalizada tanto en términos de
alimentos como de zumos insumos médicos
y el impacto de la pandemia eso ha
desatado una situación en donde la gente
ha salido a la calle ahora
independientemente de eso obviamente lo
que ha sido funcional para que la
protesta se propague por toda la isla es
el hecho de que desde hace unos años se
autorizó internet y gran parte de la
gente está conectada por celulares y eso
desde luego amplificó la protesta ahora
el uso de celulares implica que también
es posible que haya habido algún tipo de
presencia o influencia por parte de
medios externos a cuba pero yo creo que
el factor decisivo el detonante decisivo
fue la situación la difícil situación
que vive la población cubana a raíz de
la demora en introducir toda una serie
de reformas
particularmente en el modelo económico
de cuba que viene arrastrándose desde
hace muchos muchos años señor andrés es
esta crisis un nuevo reflejo de las
protestas sociales que se ven en el
resto de países latinoamericanos y que
hemos visto desde hace un par de años si
yo lo he señalado en varios artículos
recientes justamente estaba señalando el
fin de la excepcionalidad cubana siempre
creemos que hubo era como un caso aparte
de lo que está pasando en américa latina
pero en realidad se ajusta a la
tendencia generalizada de reacción de la
población y frente a las élites cada vez
más deslegitimada las élites gobernantes
ya sea políticas o en algunos casos con
un componente militar y a un incremento
de las demandas insatisfechas por parte
de la población en lo cual no solamente
sucede en cubahora sino que es está
venido sucediendo en los últimos años
inclusive antes de la pandemia en toda
américa latina
consecuentemente yo creo que cada vez
menos cuba puede ser considerado un caso
aparte en américa latina más allá de la
situación de presión y sanciones
económicas por parte de eeuu y en
términos de los procesos sociales cada
vez más más identificada con lo que está
sucediendo en el resto de américa
latina' de las tendencias que se están
desarrollando bueno diría usted que una
de las causas de esta inflamación social
es el fin de la era castro se está
mermando el apoyo al modelo del partido
comunista en la isla ahora con miguel
díaz canel al frente pero hay una nueva
generación de gobernantes dirigentes en
cuba que ya no responde a lo que fue la
generación que hizo la revolución de los
veteranos de la revolución de aquellos
que vivieron en la sierra maestra quedan
pocos raúl es uno de ellos desde luego
pero raúl estaba alejado del poder ayer
si se reunió de nuevo con el buró
político del partido comunista a raíz de
los eventos del domingo pero en general
la responsabilidad lo que está
sucediendo es de una nueva generación
que ha sido
y socializada y formada en el marco de
el aparato burocrático existente en el
aparato estatal y del partido comunista
consecuentemente las capas la capacidad
de responder frente a este tipo de
crisis es menor y yo diría mucho más
estructurada y rígida que la capacidad
que tenía la generación anterior
pongo un caso muy breve como ejemplo
cuando se produjo el maleconazo en 1994
fidel castró a pasivo la situación
personal
se nos acaba el tiempo muchísimas
gracias por este análisis y por estar
con nosotros con un saldo hasta el
momento de al menos 150 restricción
fallecimiento
veremos cómo avanzan las protestas en
cubas sigan con nosotros en france 24 o
en día
[Música]